Speaker 1: Christian nationalism is something
we've spoken about a lot on the program.
Christian nationalism is very, generally speaking,
a view where you believe that Christianity
should be not only one of many religions that
people in their private lives can choose to
follow, but directly connected to the law
of the land and civil government.
Christian nationalism includes the idea that
the doctrine of Christianity should be first
and foremost and in the forefront of what
determines what are civil laws and civil government.
Now, Congresswoman Lauren Boebert from Colorado,
who recently just barely, barely, barely won
reelection.
She recently made some comments about Jesus
and Christianity.
And it's really the stuff of nightmares.
She spoke about the end times and the rapture.
And let's look at the clip first.
But I want you to just have in mind and I
know I've said this before and people get
offended.
What is the line between religion and delusional
mental illness when it comes to the sorts
of stuff she talks about?
I don't pretend to know the answer, but let's
listen to what she said.
Speaker 2: And one thing that I love, just
an analogy.
Maybe, maybe it's true.
Maybe it's not about the second coming of
Jesus.
I've heard stories of people believing that
Christians are going to be hiding out in caves
and, you know, in just lockdown.
Maybe maybe it's a lockdown, maybe it's a
government lockdown.
But they're shut in and they beg for Jesus
to come back.
He comes back and rescues them.
I don't think that that's the way it's going
to be.
As if the Old Testament is a type in the shadow
of the New Testament.
And you look at the exodus from Egypt.
Pharaoh, he was the one who called for God
to get his people.
He said, Get your people out of here.
And I believe if if that type in shadow is
true for the New Testament, the Church, God's
people will be out in such a great force that
Satan himself will call for the second coming
of Jesus.
You say, I cannot do a thing in this earth
with your people.
Here you come and get them.
Speaker 1: Come on.
Wow.
Incredibly powerful stuff.
Now, I really need you to understand what
she's talking about here.
This second coming of Jesus stuff, resurrection,
rapture, end times.
This is all you know, there's different flavors.
And I know no matter which summary I give,
someone will write in and say, David, you're
misunderstanding this or that aspect of it.
Remember, there's a thousand versions of this,
but it is some combination of there is going
to be some kind of end time event where the
Christians that are alive and the resurrected
believers are going to rise in the clouds.
And here on earth, bad things are going to
happen in some of these versions.
All of the Jews die and some of these Virgin
Virgins versions, 144,000 Jews survive.
There's every everything under the sun.
It's all pretty bonkers.
Okay.
From just an earthly perspective, and it is
apparently in some circles not only acceptable
but welcomed to hear elected officials talking
in this way.
And they use these beliefs to inform what
they believe the law should be.
For example, the very same place that Lauren
Boebert gets, the ideas you just heard, she
gets her ideas about abortion, which then
she uses to say, Here's what the law should
be, even though we're supposed to have separation
of church and state.
So comments like these are just completely
appalling.
And her desire to inject this sort of stuff
into civil government is an obvious violation
of the separation of church and state.
It if if, if she got her way, it would lead
to unofficial discrimination and marginalization
of non-Christians, of non religious people
altogether.
And it is one of the scariest things that
is going on right now as a movement within
the Republican Party.
Yeah, MAGA stuff, it's wacky.
It's scary.
Space lasers, all of it, right?
It's crazy.
But the Christian nationalism stuff is particularly
dangerous.
Here is another clip from the same interview.
This was the Faith in Action podcast, I guess.
Lauren Boebert says God tells her reelection
would be like the Prophet Elijah in the Bible,
defeating the prophets of Baal.
This is this is what God said to her.
I don't know if this was like at a cafe, at
a bar or in private prayer.
Speaker 2: Well, totally.
But and then this one, it was just the Democrat
and myself.
He campaigned as a Republican.
The media allowed him to do that.
They called him a conservative.
Right.
Just allowed him to define himself as that
is bizarre.
But I guess, again, with 51% of the vote,
barely just took a lot longer to get there.
But, you know, throughout all of this, I was
telling you, you know, God was really pressing
on my heart.
The story of Elijah.
Speaker 1: Okay.
She's saying God spoke to her.
Okay.
I really need get everybody to understand.
She is saying that a man in the sky, I think
they still say he's a man of sorts or a masculine
entity in the sky.
Spoke to her about specific passages in the
context of her reelection.
Speaker 2: He said the true God will answer
by fire and those who worshiped Bale.
They they believe that Bale was.
Speaker 1: Oh, I said Ball, I guess it's Bale,
the.
Speaker 2: True God, he said.
I said, Prove it.
If Bale is a true God, tell him to answer
by fire.
And they're calling for him.
They're screaming, They're hollering.
They're cutting themselves or act in a pool.
You know, we've seen that like in 2020 riots.
Stop, Right?
But their God didn't show up.
Elijah was mocking them yet.
Well, maybe cry a little bit louder.
Maybe he can't hear you.
Maybe he's sleeping.
Maybe he's on vacation.
I love that so much.
And then he went.
He said, You know what?
I'm going to do you one better.
I don't want you to say that this is some
kind of fluke, some sort of combustion that
just happened.
I'm going to drench the altar with fire or
with water three times.
Speaker 1: Fire or water, whichever three.
Speaker 2: Times to wet and drench the altar
with fire and God with water.
And God still showed up by fire.
And that's what he was showing you at this
election.
He said it may look impossible in the natural
that there will not be a victory.
You may hear the voices, you may hear other
people, but I am going to show up.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, these are always
stories that are that are told with the hindsight
of knowing how the election turned up.
She barely won and she could have lost.
Would she still be telling the story?
Listen, God came to me and he said, Your reelection
is going to be like when Prophet Elijah defeated
the prophets of Bel, then she loses.
Oh, I guess God was wrong.
No, but God, God is never wrong and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
This is the sort of stuff, even if they don't
say it, that a lot of members of Congress
are thinking when they think about how they
are legislating.
Now, I know many of you will write in and
say, but you know, David, this it's really
not a big deal because you look at in Italy,
everybody's Catholic.
You know, all the elected officials are Catholic
and it is no big deal.
It's really important to understand that not
all religions are the same.
And I know lots of Italian Catholics.
I have many Italian Catholic friends.
What it means to them to be Catholic is a
very different thing than what it means for
evangelicals.
Like I believe she's evangelical Lauren Boebert
to be evangelical and the comfort that folks
like Boebert have, even despite the separation
of church and state that we're supposed to
have, saying things like we need Christian
nationalism, we need the church to be guiding
government.
And all of the things I've covered her saying
over recent years, a lot of people with some
connection to reality would be embarrassed
to be on video saying the things that Lauren
Boebert says, not not for the religious reasons,
but because it would be seen as so inappropriate
to come out and say, I believe that my religion,
not just religion, but my religion, not anybody
else's, not any other religions, should be
dictating how government works.
You talk to Catholic politicians in Italy
who are nominally Catholic and would consider
themselves religious in the way that many
Europeans do.
They would be humiliated to be caught saying
things like what Lauren Boebert says.
So it's not all the same.
And it's a really important thing to understand
this particular brand of Christian nationalism
that often comes from born again Christians
and evangelicals, etc.
It's not just kind of wacky in terms of the
things they say it is, but it's not only that.
It also is extraordinarily dangerous in terms
of what it would mean if they got their way.
And when you look at what's happening in the
Supreme Court and Amy Coney Barrett and others
who are on that court, who at least to some
degree share a lot of these views, you realize
that if things keep going the direction that
they've been going, it's not completely out
of the question that in some ways the boebert
types could get their way.
And that's a horrifying thing to think about.